turning overseas where former Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
appears to be on the brink of being the
current prime minister again once again
his right-wing Coalition has the most
votes as of now after Israel's fifth
election in four years a little
refresher on Netanyahu he was forced to
step down last year amid corruption
charges which by the way he is still
currently on trial for right now MTS
tyab is following all of it from London
MTS they're saying it could be the most
right-wing government in Israel in years
if not ever good morning
Tony good morning to you yes well it
looks all that certain Benjamin
Netanyahu will make an extraordinary
comeback from the political Wilderness
but as you say his return is being
directly tied to the rise of his allies
Israel's extreme right and
ultra-orthodox political parties for the
first time ever the far right have won
the third largest number of seats in
Israel's parliament one of the main
parties known as the Jewish power party
is led by itamar Ben gavir his rhetoric
is stridently anti-palestinian he
suggested imposing the death penalty on
Palestinians convicted of on attacks on
Jewish people now this sharp shift right
where it comes at a time of mounting
violence since January a series of
Palestinian attacks have killed 19
people across Israel what more than 130
Palestinians have been killed in
confrontations with Israeli forces
making this the deadliest year since
2005. netanyahu's return to power also
fuels concerns by Arab neighbors he will
continue to obstruct negotiations for a
Palestinian state but Allied Gulf
countries see Netanyahu as a powerful
culture counterweight rather to Iran's
growing influence across the region Gail
MTS tayab reporting from London we thank
you